punch in a little bit later yeah check
check we're talking about jimmy and dr
dre
jimmy iveen is the levitator dre is the
innovator
i need something a little bit more
impressive
bruce taught me a work ethic i had to
work harder than the next guy just to do
as well as the next guy and to do better
than the next guy
i had to kill i knew that i had to be a
success at something a friend of mine
put together
two turntables i started doing this
thing
i wanted to be able to get in there and
rock
i think rattling home was jimmy's last
stand i think we broke him
i didn't want to see a studio i was done
i said hey back i started record company
i got to find
great producers and i produced them
this was that do or die album put my
body into this record
i'm playing it for everybody for some
reason everybody's turning me down
nobody wanted to deal with this gangsta
rap thing they were afraid to deal with
the people
the east coast ain't got no love but dr
dre is snooped up
interschool crossed the line of decency
all i remember is that draya came in to
play us the chronic i said who recorded
this for you
he said me i said wow
this guy will define inner scope
jimmy was like i want to get you guys on
the cover of the rolling stones magazine
you guys are like making keith i'm like
well
it's making keith the rolling stone
magazine i want to be on the source
magazine cover
that blew up i mean i never had that
many white people coming to me in my
whole life
okay so fast forward to holy this is
jimmy ivy
holy dr dre just walked in he pops that
tape and
i'm blown away i'm myself now thinking
about it
jimmy iving he was walking up the beach
and i told him about
my lawyer approaching me about a sneaker
company that wants you to endorse
something out of the blue he's like dre
man eat sneakers no you don't sell
sneakers you sell
all kinds of different speakers yeah you
know what
we could call it beats
everything that i've done in my career
i've always been underestimated
fear's a powerful thing it's got a lot
of firepower
it was the beginning of making fear a
tailwind instead of a headwind
you